look into this video playing King guest
king st 1912 from Turkey so the week's
change yeah I'm playing all kinds of
weird lights against this let's go with
one of them which will be seven KD force
it's possible not to move that frightens
black very much but playable yeah my
special recipe is Bishop f6 the
debatable after moves like night be
three black is very much ok Andy five
yeah it's them I want to provoke trying
to prove that this is not a good movie 5
in the upcoming endgame sort of like
comparable to the Berlin yeah I'm not
sure about this but it's interesting so
c5 and there should be six next going to
f3 uh-huh what's more thinking about
night be three but ok maybe maybe his
ride there should be six the fico bishop
is sexy a might keep the Queen's on not
sure even if I take on d 1 and player
should be six he has 95 maybe we should
be eight ok interesting
yeah that looks a lot like the London
end game what difference is i can still
castle yeah now he he allows me to take
hear what I that I don't mind at all
it's very well known that this trade is
is good for black in the Berlin or at
least them nothing to worry about what
I'm talking about is the trade of the
dark squared bishop against the night
yeah this is just a good end game for
black plain and simple 'if I've tends to
be a weakness and the bishop is stronger
than the night ok Bishop f5 or maybe
Bishop f5 it's a simple way to play c2
is just weak ok ok Knight c3 is still a
good reply
ok
a Bishop Bishop f5 was too early was
just too early hmm stupid stupid play so
I lost a bit of time no can also blame
the I can also just play here look the
eight is probably not very effective
wondering about about a five if I went
c4 maybe this one and totally sure about
about 95 okay
trying to get rid of them off the double
pond okay he's attacking this after all
rook c8 has probably night a seven
coming but this is not not a big deal
really why should I take first
at this moment I just recognize that
have spent I've spent far too much time
in position is perfectly okay of course
but I have fur I have spent far too much
time black es is better now i have the
king in the middle and i quickly will
get my pawns rolling with the better
minor piece 94 i don't think was very
successful we should play maybe night 87
95 playing playing for tricks maybe f5
takes 95 from thats not ready not very
dangerous Jack don't see how he saves
the porn really the other the only line
morning the only serious problem here is
the clock
how does he even stopped there partner
the bishop here dominates the night
completely
yeah the a point we'll just promote and
a2 a2 coming white forfeits due to
disconnection mmm job okay yeah I'm not
quite i'm not sure if if white really
assess this end game correctly i mean i
have a suspicion that you thought that
maybe he's better word which is not the
case in this position i only black has
chances it probably should be a draw but
if anyone black can do something i have
the better mine a priest long-term with
the bishop those pawns are on light
squares and that will be able to get rid
of my double pawn um as mentioned it
should be a draw but i don't think i
should ever ever be in trouble maybe i'm
around here he must must improve i think
this is most likely not very good
probably probably okay for an hour I
don't know well I take he captures and
now I go here c5 c4 is a threat I mean I
guess so he should react to it somehow
h3c five may I'm too too optimistic a
comp is still on equal i was i was
thinking that around here white already
needs to proceed with some caution but
it seems that this is so perfectly
perfectly okay he's got this counter
play coming and rook t6 rookie 695 m
okay this is certainly enough activity
sure but how did it how did it go wrong
for him let's check there should be six
and I hear the compass slowly seeing
that black is really better d3i this is
chat very critical now and after f5 rook
takes ah yes a draw funny he has a draw
with f6 check how is this wrong ah very
nice very nice that's not easy at all
for human to see check check night f5
check this is very strong if i take my
rook is hanging and um this is wait just
a moment i want to check it what about
this okay six probably a draw okay
probably a draw so I have to play King
yet King fa this checkmate not very
successful so here and then I g7 secures
the draw quite funny b7 just a very
weird perpetual ok so then only this
move was losing yeah he definitely has
lost the a pawn will promote I'm
interesting okay thanks for watching